but we begin with breaking news here at
11 o'clock Metro Police say a person
violently attacked a bus driver after
barricading themselves on the bus then
went on to assault several police
officers as well Madison Kimbrough is
live at the scene Madison joins us now
with more
yeah this happened just before seven
this evening and as you can see it's
still an active scene this is what we
know so far several officers have been
injured as a man who is said to have
battered a bus driver barricaded himself
inside the bus now that man is now in
custody with other suspects it's unclear
what led up to the physical dispute but
police say there were several attempts
to make verbal communication with the
suspects before officers were injured
the bus driver's condition is unknown at
this time and we don't know how many
officers are hurt or what their injuries
are currently Durango is shut down just
north of Blue Diamond they are wrapping
up the scene as we speak but is still
very active out here but of course keep
it here on 8 news now for the latest
details also 8newsnow.com reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 news now Madison
thank you for reference this is the same
intersection we're an RTC bus was
hijacked earlier this year in January a
Woman Led police and a brief Chase
inside the stolen bus before being taken
to the custody